Юлія Тимошенко обіцяє знизити ціну на газ вдвічі, якщо стане президентом України.
За її словами, це буде її першим кроком.
Юлія Тимошенко наводить два факти, які на її думку,
підтверджують можливість зменшення ціни на "блакитне паливо".
Перший - населення споживає 15,8 мільярда кубометрів газу.
А власний видобуток України становить 16,4 мільярда кубометрів.
Таким чином, робить висновок кандидатка у президенти,
українського газу більше ніж вистачає для людей.
Цифри взяті за підсумками 2017 року.
Однак, 16,4 мільярда кубометрів газу – це загальний видобуток газу у державному секторі.
Тобто результат роботи трьох компаній –
"Укргаздобування", "Укрнафти" та "Чорноморнафтогаз".
Втім, згідно із постановою Кабміну, газ для населення постачає лише "Укргазвидобування",
сто відсотків акцій якої належать державі.
А ця компанія у 2017 році видобула для потреб населення близько 13,9 мільярда кубометрів газу,
тобто майже на 2 мільярди менше, ніж було потрібно.
Роком раніше за використаних населенням 17,6 мільярда кубометрів "блакитного палива",
Укргаздобування видобула іще менше - 13 мільярдів.
Отже, всупереч заяві Тимошенко, Україна добуває недостатньо газу для своїх потреб
і без імпорту поки не обійтися.
Загалом же щороку на населення, тепло, бюджетні установи, промисловість тощо,
Україна використовує більше тридцяти мільярдів кубометрів газу.
Кандидатка пропонує збільшити обсяг внутрішнього видобутку "блакитного палива"
й подальшого продажу його населенню за нижчою ціною.
Зробити це у найближчі 3-5 років дійсно реально,
якщо інвестувати у це понад три мільярди доларів, вважають газові експерти.
Власне, чинний уряд це і так планує зробити, згідно з Національною стратегією сталого розвитку
до 2020-го року видобуток власного газу повинен зрости до понад 27 млрд кубометрів.
З них 20 мільярдів - повинна була видобувати державна компанія "Укргазвидобування ",
а решту - приватний сектор.
Втім, торік "Укргазвидобування" видобуло лише 15,5 мільярда кубометрів газу.
Проте досягти запланованих показників можна лише за умови,
якщо вдасться подолати корупцію і бюрократію у цій галузі,
а також вирішити проблему олігархічного впливу.
І встигнути зробити це до кінця року, вочевидь, неможливо.
Зокрема, у "Нафтогазі" скаржаться - систематичне блокування видачі дозволів
на розвідку та розробку надр фактично зірвало плани уряду
по збільшенню видобутку вітчизняного газу.
Друга теза Юлії Тимошенко,
яка підтверджує можливість удвічі зменшити ціну на "блакитне паливо" -
реальна вартість газу разом з податками,
транспортуванням та прибутком на розвиток галузі - три з половиною гривні.
Але українці платять значно більше - вісім з половиною гривень за кубометр,
вважає кандидатка в президенти, яка обіцяє українцям дешевий газ.
Теоретично таке можливо, але наслідки будуть найгірші з усіх можливих - пояснюють експерти.
Низькі ціни на газ для населення вже не перший рік призводили до дефіциту "Нафтогазу",
який доводилося компенсувати вливаннями з держбюджету.
Саме через це МВФ вимагав перейти на ринкові ціни,
тобто державні компанії мають працювати у таких самих умовах, як і приватні.
А увесь газ - імпортний та український,
держкомпаній та приватних - має продаватися за ринковими цінами.
Якщо ж певні категорії споживачів не можуть повністю сплачувати за спожитий газ,
мають отримувати субсидії - зазначають економісти.
Окрім того, коли ціни для населення низькі, а для промисловості високі, ринкові,
то відкривається шлях до старих корупційних схем.
Наприклад, коли газопостачальник начебто задешево купує газ
для продажу п обутовим споживачам, але насправді продає задорого  промисловості,
а різницю в ціні кладе собі в кишеню.
Саме тому варто урівняти ціну для населення і промисловості, вважають експерти.
Варто також зазначити, що сфера тарифів перебуває в компетенції уряду, а не президента,
тому, навіть якщо Юлію Тимошенко і оберуть президентом,
вона не зможе юридично виконати свою обіцянку, окрім як ініціювати законопроект.
Але це вона може зробити і нині як народна депутатка.
Знизити ціну на газ удвічі теоретично можливо,
але це матиме вкрай погані наслідки для економіки країни,
а отже, призведе до подальшого збідніння населення.
Крім того, поверне корупційні схеми перепродажу газу,
а по-друге, покладе край співпраці з МВФ, умовою фінансової допомоги якого
є підвищення тарифів на "блакитне паливо" для населення.